بهدف وحيد مشاهدينا للاسباني رودري توج
مانشستر سيتي الانجليزي بدوري ابطال
اوروبا للمره الاولى في تاريخه
الفريق السماوي خطف الفوز امام انتر ميلان
الايطاليه ليكمل ثلاثيه تاريخيه طبعا اضاف
لقب دوري الابطال الى جانب الدوري
الانجليزي وايضا كاس انجلترا خلال هذا
الموسم ليصبح ثاني الفرق الانجليزيه التي
تكتب او تكتب هذا الانجاز بعد غريمه
مانشستر يونايتد بهذا الانجاز ايضا اصبح
بيب غوارديولا اول مدرب يفوز بالثلاثيه
لكن مع فريقين مختلفين حيث حققها سابقا مع
برشلونه
خلال موسم عام 2009
مزعجه بالفعل وخساره النهائيه امام تشيلسي
عام 2021
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات